At this point, we've seen how
polynomials can be represented by their
values, as a set of distinct inputs, and
how multiplying polynomials is easy,
when they're represented in this way.
The problem is that we're really
interested in the coefficients.
Recall that the coefficients of
the two polynomials can represent
any two sequences that
we want to convolve.
To exploit the speed of multiplying
in the value representation,
therefore, we need an efficient way,
first to evaluate a polynomial
at some distinct set of input points,
and an efficient way to interpolate
back the result to
the coefficient representation.
We'll focus on optimizing for quick
evaluation of the polynomials first.
Our goal is to evaluate a polynomial
A of order N at N distinct points.
Note that I've made the order
of the polynomial and
the number of points the same here.
We can always pad
the coefficients with zeroes,
effectively increasing the order,
and we can always add more points.
So there's no loss of generality here.
As you did the calculation for the
exercise, you may have taken advantage
of the fact that the input values were
arranged in positive and negative pairs.
For higher order polynomials,
this advantage becomes even greater.
All the even terms are the same for
x and negative x, and
the odd terms are just
negatives of each other.
With this in mind let's define
A sub e to be the polynomial whose
coefficients are the even coefficients
of the original polynomial A.
And we'll define Ao to be
the polynomial whose coefficients
are the odd coefficients of
the original polynomial A.
Then we can write A as
A sub e of x squared,
plus x times A sub o of x squared.
And we can get A of minus x just by
changing this one little sign here.
And essentially we've found two
values for A for the price of one.
More formally, let's say that
we choose x sub i such that
x of i is equal to negative
x of I plus N over two.
Then we can compute the values of the
polynomial two at a time by computing
Ae and Ao at Xi squared and
then using them in these two equations.
Overall we have changed
the problem from evaluating
a polynomial of order and
at end points to evaluating two
polynomials of order N over
two at N over two points.
Plus doing the work of N more
additions and multiplications.
This is good, but
at its best we've only reduced
the running time by a constant factor.
We need to be able to apply
this strategy recursively
to change the asontonic running time.
A set of points that would allow us to
do this would be very special indeed.